all right so this is a there's a new
project that's you know under a year old
and we're kind of integrating the long
term approach of Jane and Diane and data
collection with some new technologies to
really try and get at the in various
ways weaning and mountain gorillas and
chimpanzees the two animals that are
most like us that are most likely some
sort of representative for where we came
from okay this is in partnership with
many many people but in the Jane Goodall
Institute the Fauci Fund Max Planck
Institute my institution Franklin and
Marshall College and George Washington
University and we've got cute baby apes
there so that's always good okay so the
first thing we aim to do in this project
is to really well characterize those
dietary transitions from exclusively
feeding on Mother's Milk to that
transition to solid food and we know
that that it's a process not not a hard
line and the way we have done this up to
this point is by doing behavioral
observations by watching these Apes for
years and years and years and
documenting when they're suckling at
their mother's breast and when they
start feeding on solid food now remember
I mentioned to you that weaning and Apes
takes four to seven years it's a really
long period of time and of course
they're eating solid food well before
seven years old and so what we want to
do in this project is really narrow that
window or understand that window much
better and so in addition to this
behavioral approach of really analyzing
our long-term data for suckling behavior
and eating solid foods what we're doing
is collecting a lot of a poop okay a
poop is gold in my world like you can
find out so many things from a poop you
have no idea how stressed they are what
diseases they have like what they ate
yesterday it's amazing one of the newer
things you can find out from a poop as
if you analyze the stable isotopes in
that poop you can actually figure out
what trophic level an infant is relative
to its mother so you can measure stable
isotopes of nitrogen and essentially if
the kid is enriched in nitrogen relative
to the
that means that that kid is still a
trophic level above the mom ie I'm still
eating mom I'm still feeding primarily
on mom right and when the levels of
nitrogen come down to the same as mom
you know that the contribution of
mother's milk to the diet has leveled
off and they're eating surviving
primarily on solid food so this has been
done in one study in great apes by
yuliya Buddhist ku and this is don't
worry about what the graph is saying all
that much what's important is that
horizontal line is infant age in months
and anything above the line is when the
kid is eating mom and anything on the
line is when the kid is not and what
this graph tells you is that around 25
to 30 months old the kid looks just like
the mom the kid is no longer eating mom
at that point that's less than a
three-year-old and remember I told you
that weaning occurs between four and
seven so they're nutritionally
independent of mom well before they stop
weaning which is kind of weird right so
we want to narrow that window a little
bit more understand that a little bit
better get more data from chimps and
also from gorillas because that type of
work has never been done in gorillas the
second thing we want to do is figure out
that huge window four to seven years old
what are the sources of variation in
there there's various theory that would
suggest that that might change depending
on maternal age whether mom is large
body size or in better body condition
there's some theory that suggests that
infants have to reach a particular size
themselves to be weaned so infant size
for age birth order maybe firstborn kids
are different than second born kids
maybe infant sex matters we just have no
idea what could contribute to this big
variation that we see so a lot of these
variables we can understand from our
long-term records right maternal age we
knew who these moms are we know when
they were born we know how old they are
but and I should say I say that like
it's really simple it's only because
these studies have been going on more
than 50 years okay so let me let me
really point that out there that's why
we know that we know the birth order
we know the infant sex obviously but we
don't have or we didn't have until
recently a good non-invasive way to
study size in
animals attempts to measure a wild
chimpanzee or gorilla will fail if you
ask them to step on a scale or hold up a
ruler
I mean you might not get the ruler or
your arm back so we've had to develop
ways that that do this without
disturbing them and what's come out of
some research actually on horses and
other Amal's is this approach of a
parallel laser photogrammetry
so essentially you build this box here
on the Left which that's the exact box I
just built in December you try to get it
through airport security all the way to
Tanzania which was surprisingly easy and
what that does is it's a series of it's
a laser beam split by two prisms and
they're perfectly parallel all the time
and because they're perfectly parallel
all the time they're always exactly 4
centimeters apart so you take that to
the field
you give your collaborators the box they
put it on a camera they pointed at a
chimp and now you have a scale you're
projecting something exactly 4
centimeters apart onto a wild animal you
can use that as a scale to measure body
size ok that's that's that our little
scale blown up because those dots are
pretty hard to see this doesn't bother
them these chimpanzees are used to weird
people pointing weird stuff at them all
the time because the studies been going
on 60 years so this doesn't bother them
so again we're doing this in both
gorillas and chimpanzees to try and suss
out some of these sources of variation
NewTek with long term data
[Music]